cicely tyson was so much more than an
actress
she was in many ways all we had she was
a representation
of african americans when it came to
television
when it came to so many things can you
kind of
put that into context i i i loved what
viola davis said
i thought she said it well you made me
feel loved and seen and valued in a
world where there is still a cloak up in
visibility for us dark chocolate girls
you gave me permission to dream
wow that was system tyson i mean when i
got the news yesterday when i got the
phone call
it i felt like i like someone had
punched me in the chest
you know at 96 you can't say
death is unexpected but in this case it
was unexpected to me because i had just
seen her kevin a week ago
she was so engaging and she was so
full of life and she was talking about
things that she still had that she still
wanted to do she said i still want to
direct
she said you know it's better than in
her book it's better than sitting at
home leaving butt prints
i mean those were her words
she still felt that she had other things
that she wanted to do and was looking
forward to doing
so on one hand you know i grieve her
passing on the other hand i celebrate
her life
i feel so grateful and so
happy that i got to spend the time with
her you know a week ago
a week ago so it's it's a it's a
i feel i feel conflicted about the
emotions i'm feeling right now at this
moment
because how can you not smile when you
think about cicely tyson
no she was grace she was class she was
essential
tyson was and i asked her do you think
about death she said of course i think
about death i've lost many friends
but i feel as long as you're still
breathing you still have work to do
so it was it was this you know i i said
this wasn't a daughtering old woman i
didn't ask her questions about
how do you want to be remembered and do
you think about death because i thought
death was near
i only asked the question because she
was 96 the united states
knows but you know to to live right
till the very end where you still have
all of your mental faculties with you
and your health is good
kevin that's a really good life very
good life
i've done interviews with her before you
know i feel comforted and
and honored that i got to be one of her
final interviews
and i talked to her years ago i mean her
stories about she doesn't take a role
unless
it speaks to her that she feels a
tingling of her skin that she can
inherit the character and the roles that
she wanted to
to play to portray black women to show
the humanity of the black race
these weren't just acting jobs to her
she saw this as using her platform
she was extraordinary extraordinary
gail i i think that in this is one case
where
tyler were you where oprah at least we
had a chance to recognize and
honor cicely and and thank her for what
she had
done and he knew it kevin she knew
that's the other thing
you know she didn't have to pass away
without people she knew exactly how
loved she was and how people felt about
her and so that gives me great joy she
knew it
you know today as you probably know is
oprah's birthday today is oprah's
birthday
you know what she's doing to celebrate
she and steadman
are watching the autobiography of jane
pitts
just the two of them one of the reasons
why oprah had the
famous legends ball was because of
cicely tyson
that is no joke she wanted to pay
tribute to women who have come before
her
and cicely tyson was number one on her
list she wanted to pay tribute to women
who had made it
black women who had made a difference in
her life and cicely tyson was number one
on the list so
you can you could almost say if it
hadn't been for oprah's relationship
with cicely tyson
i don't know that we would have had a
legends ball and you
now ain't got no husband ain't got no
boyfriend and you holed up in this bed
like the queen of sheba
just had her back covered she told me
that being able to play viola davis mom
and how to get away with murder
was one of the great honors of her life
she was thrilled at viola she said i
heard that viola herself
asked for me she said do you know what
that meant to me
i mean here's cece tyson talking about
she was so honored i mean while viola is
saying
can you believe that cicely tyson is
going to play my mother
i mean you know the other thing i
thought was interesting when i talked to
her when
president barack obama gave her the
presidential medal of freedom
and he said it was gorgeous did you hear
he said and she's
she was so tickled with that she was so
tickled with
with life and how she knew people loved
and admired her but kevin it's always
nice to hear it
you know the thing that got me too was
when she broke down
um in the interview when she was talking
about a me too moment when before we
even called it me too
she had gone to an acting coach she made
a pass of her
you know grabbed her hair was forcing
her into a position she didn't want to
go
and i said why did you go back why did
you go back
she go she goes i wasn't going to let
him deprive me of my dream
i wasn't going to do that and i said but
why did you go back to him she
she held her finger and said i didn't go
back to him i went back to class
to get what i was entitled to to do the
job that i wanted to do
and she's such a lady because you know
intelligent you know we want the details
i go
what exactly was he trying to get you to
do and she said
gail you know exactly what he he was
grabbing me by my hair
you know exactly what he wanted me to do
and she said
i've said it what i said and i will go
no further
just like this and i will go no further
i mean you know
i felt like you you have to sit up a
little straighter in her presence
because she was such a lady
how how loving was she and a mothering
figure
was she well she was loving she was kind
i mean she you know she's revered she
knows that many people sought her advice
about things
because we just wanted to know what does
cicely think
what does she think how is she feeling
about this moment
i mean you know i'm so glad that we have
the book just as i am
she said i didn't write this as a memoir
because many people see me as a
christmas tree with lights and ornaments
and it's dazzling
it would have meant the world to her for
you
to tell her story today what do you
think she would say to you today
well she doesn't have to say anything to
me i say everything to her
the only thing i said to her over and
over again is thank you
thank you thank you thank you she
doesn't have anything to say to me i
i i bow down to all things cecily tyson
and i'm just i'm filled with gratitude
that i got to be
one of her final interviews it will mean
everything to me
you